migrant center in the italian city of
traviso is being blamed for a spike in
coveted infections
center in a former military barracks has
been criticized after more than 200
people
fell victim to coronavirus in just two
weeks
travisso had been considered a coveted
free city
the mayor himself has stopped the
situation a health bomb
what happened inside the serene x
military barracks structure directly
managed by the ministry of interior is a
paradox
the structure didn't work fine in normal
conditions and it showed all its gaps
during this health emergency
we call it a health bomb because there
are 256 people confined into the same
structure
and they don't want to separate between
covert 19 positive cases
and negative ones prosecutors this month
launched a probe after the first
positive cases were discovered in the
migrant centre
and public anger at the situation is
growing
they put too many immigrants together it
was inevitable
now the danger is young people who do
not distance themselves
but virologists say that the virus has
weakened
the problem is not just inside the
barracks it seems to me that the
situation is out of control
more serious and correct messages needed
but right now they don't know how to
deal with it
there is some concern it's a shame that
our politicians have left us in disarray
without a solution i thought i would go
back but younger people and migrants
aren't taking it seriously
we all need to be conscientious and be
more careful
it's better not to talk about the serena
issue it was bad management it continues
to be bad
the root of the problem must be solved
move the migrants and give them a chance
to live a decent life
i'm very worried we were free from covet
and now there are all these new cases
the fault lies with those letting the
migrants in they should be sent back
home
this comes as four migrants were also
arrested in august for allegedly
starting a revolt there
there have been reports too that some
refugees escaped quarantine which may
have contributed to the kobe crisis
migrants have also been accused of
attacking health workers which is what
triggered
the following response from politicians
the virus must not leave the barracks
for me the barracks remain
a red zone from a health point of view
and guests must comply with rules
established by law
if someone who tests positive leaves
quarantine they must be fined
and criminally charged the guests are
rioting they're refusing to stay in
quarantine and destroying the infirmary
it has caused incalculable damage to the
image of the traviso
area to tourism to businesses those who
commit acts of violence must not go
unpunished
i support the decision to jail four
guests of the former serena barracks
who attacked health workers and
vandalized the rooms